This year-
♪ worn out place- ♪
-was so involved.
(intense dramatic music overlapped with the sounds of hell)
It's hard to believe that it all happened in a single year.
♪ smooth guitar ♪
I look back at 2018 and I kind of... try to catalog all the different things that happened in this year-
*quick smooch*
-and I can not understand how this all happened this year.
I don't believe that I was in Europe at the beginning of this year,
but I was.
(Ethan): I SAID GET READY TO CUM.
So this year was very involved.
I'm not sure even where to begin,
but I thought I'd do a little recap...
of everything that happened this year...
UHHH
and just go from there, and then talk about what's gonna happen in the next year.
Cause I got big plans for this next year!
I got big plans that I'm gonna be doing.
Uhm
I just dunno know how to do it yet.
I do know how to do it! That's a lie.
I've been putting my plans in motion
since before even the year started.
I-It-It's not that I don't know what I'm doing,
I do know what I'm doing.
*doesn't even believe himself*
I know what I'm doing.
So...
I made a mistake.
(gasping for air)
I made ANOTHER mistake
(big booms as the words pop up)
And then I went on tour.
And I went on tour in America and in Europe.
Europe was great!
(intense dubstep)
Then we fell in love!..
with me!
(mega chill music)
We fell in loveee!
(cork pops off)
I sold a rock.
(spooky deep voice) Whiiiiiiite
(chuckling)
I sold a rock!
HeHA
(automated voice repeating "sex")
And then I went to one video a day, from two videos a day.
Probably the biggest change in my channel,
just in how I approach content has been that change.
But it's also been the best.
It's NOT an excuse...
to get lazy.
BUT
It is an excuse to...
*inhale*
…do other stuff.
Cause in all honesty I think it turned out way for the best
That's not words.
I think it turned out for the best because
I...
*inhale*
was able to do what I wanted to do what I wanted to do
when I wanted to do it.
And that was good!
*awkwardness intensifies*
That's not a good reasoning.
I was able to put more...
work into every single video by creating like the 3 videos,
Three games in a video videos, three video
video in the video videos.
You ever have that many videos in a video? No,
not that many videos.
*blows into lips*
And then, uhm, I made a promise
(Past Mark) : I'm gonna be going to one video a day.
- and then I broke that promise.
(slow mo Mark says "oh no")
But, that was obvious because
we sold- OH! I got naked!
(Tropical music starts)
I got REAL naked.
(Tropical music starts again)
I got super naked.
For a calendar.
Who's barking?
Anyway- I got naked
which was cool. And then I
made a promise... and then I BROKE
that promise because I had
to sign all of the calendars from me getting naked.
I signed thirty-eight thousand
calendars, which was something
...bad.
(Past Mark): My fingies (fingers) are
tired. *sad chuckling*
(Mark): I ate a ghost pepper.
(Past Mark): OOOohh
(Mark): And then I DIDN'T eat a ghost pepper
*static noise when a wild BITCH appears*
because that was bad for me- it probably was bad.
AND THEN I WENT INTO EXILE!
I forgot about that, I went into exile this year.
That was this year.
(Kota as Mark): I got hacked....
I was in ex- *starts laughing* -ile
(Ethan as Mark): I'll butt-chug an ENTIRE GLASS
OF PEPPER JUICE!
I was in exile. And then I came out of el-ix-ile *stutters*
*Weird Mark noises*
(Ethan as Mark): *mockingly* I'M MARKIPLIER!
I'MMA FIX YER BOOONES
And then I came out of exile, trum- trium- trum-
trumpiph.
I came out of exile
TRIUMPHANTLY.
*blows into lips again*
and that was all- that was all in the beginning of this year.
That wasn't even remotely close to *chuckles*
That's not even remotely close..to..
Wow.
Yeah, Baldi's Basics also happened this year.
(Past Mark):  *static noise* y- WHAAAA-
(Mark): D-do you believe that? Baldi's Basics was a thing this year.
(Past Mark): Oohhh noooo!! (Playtime:) WOAHHHHH
(Mark): Then I leaked my phone number, and you
broke that.. immediately.. so
thank you, for breaking that... 'cause you break everything.
(Past Mark): *distorted* This year, I made.. a promise
(Mark): THEN there was Milford Wotherlo-lu-buh- *laughing*
Then there was Wilford (Abe): Wilford
(Mark): Motherloving (Abe): Motherloving (Mark): Warfstache
(Wilford): Dave? (Mark) That came out in August.
that was more recent, that was definitely this year.
*static noise when a wild SO SMART appears*
I'm also extremely happy with how that went.
And then I made this gra-*laughter*-nd
sweeping promise
that there was gonna be more of those projects
coming at you real soon- and that wasn't that long ago-
and tha - the - the next project has
been in the works for a while, but it's taking longer
and there's been delays- and there's been...
legitimate reasons for the delays....
*awkward silence*
but I will explain that after it comes out
*static noises*
there's been a lot of mystery stuff.
*high pitched squeaking*
A lotta questions.
(Past Mark): I just want to make better conte-sa(content)
*whispers* for you guys.
(Mark): BUT
It's gonna come out... soon. Some time this year
I dunno when. When it does though,
it's gonna BLOW your mind.
*quietly* right.
And then I went to Korea
And it- Korea was great. W- honestly, truly
Korea was great because I got to see my
family, I got to make a lot of memories,
I got to live life, I got to see-
like all of these people that I've never been in-a- er --
able to interact with, I made some videos
*clapping & rustling*
I got murdered by a small child.
(Past Mark): AAahhh
(Mark): And then when I came home, I launched
*smack* CLOAK!!
CLOAK!!! LOOK AT MY NIP!!!
Clooooak! I launched
Cloak with Jack, and uhh
while also pole dancing, that was nice..
(Jack): *coughs loudly*
(Mark): And then, ahh.. *slight chuckle* then it's been
a little quiet *lip smack* a little
quiet leading up to uhm..
OH NOO! *laughs* THEN WE WENT TO AUSTRALIA!
It hasn't been quiet at all! Good God, then we
went to Australia. I petted a roo (kangaroo).
And, uhh, I almost got murdered by a
roo, but that's okay. Yeah, when I  came back there was
a whole, uhhh... I had
to do my part *organ synth cords play*
*kisses hand a whole lot*
I had to do my part for
Big Papa Pewds.
Way up high, miss you.
Miss you buddy.
♪In the arms of- ♪
Much love. Yeah, so that happened.
And then I prepared for
Christmas vacation *DEEP inhale*
then the big charity stream at the end of the year, which had SO many
technical pro- *laughs* -blems
But, it's okay. Eh, it's alright
It was very fun, and I'm really happy that
we did it. And then I came home.
(Santa Mark): He's just a big ol' pussy!
And that is a brief summary of everything
that happened this year. Now, PAY ATTENTION!
Listen, close, you're not listening.
You're off doing homework. Aye, shut up, look at me.
You weren't even talking, shut up.
Look at me now. Yes, you, look.
Alright, this next year
I can start this off by making
a bunch of grand sweeping statements about how I've got
so many resolutions to do this year,
and how I'm gonna make a big change and everything's gonna be grand and great.
So that's exactly what I'm gonna do! because that's exactly how this is gonna go down!
I don't even know if slapping this table causes...
..a ruckus.
That's what I'm gonna do. *slams the table again and starts laughing*
*repeatedly slamming the table* This is gonna be the year. (chuckling)
Shut up. Don't laugh at me. Alright, but in all seriousness...
Uhhh
Last year was incredible.
it really was there was so much that happened this past year that it's hard to believe that it was all in one year
And I've come so far in terms of you know,
personal growth ability to do (mumbles) other stuff like professional projects
whatever you want to call it like it- this year has been a big, big year for me.
Like 2017 kind of like skated by and I wasn't really paying attention but man 2018 was...
I don't know 2018 was insane.
Just with the amount of stuff
so what I want to do in this next year is I want to get back to my roots
and what that means is,
I've been doing a lot of other projects that have been outside of YouTube
and that have existed outside of the sphere of YouTube's influence.
And-
Like I've been on tour
I've been
launching all these like
businesses
and I've been doing all these big projects
and I've been having fancy meetings with fancy people and all of it's just like
It's just such a drain because it distracts from what I really want to do, which is make videos for you guys
like that's all I've ever wanted to do... And
the idea that I've gotten away from that is what really bothers me.
So this year is actually going to be the year that I actually
focus and try again at YouTube.
Because I think we can all agree that
one thing I have not been doing this year is trying...
and it's not that I've been not working hard, It's not that I've been lazy.
Some of you may disagree with that, but it's not that I've been lazy, or not working hard.
I've been working hard in the areas that haven't really...
made me feel confident in what I'm doing
You know what I mean?
In the areas that like aren't creatively fulfilling, aren't- aren't weird like aren't funny and aren't
fun to do. Aren't engaging. You know, they're not interesting. So...
in this year,
like I've got a lot of plans and ambitions and new year's resolutions to do a bunch of stuff for self-improvement
like I always do, but at the end of the day, I want to just be able to make videos again
And I want to be able to focus on that
First and foremost to give you guys cool content and make me feel like I'm actually doing something...
worthwhile while I still have the chance to do it.
So...
that's what I'm gonna do and uhh
there's no concrete plans to that except for these exact concrete plans that I'm about to outline right now.
I wanna do... *slam* Markiplier Makes Mondays,
*slam* Markiplier Tries Tuesdays,
*slam* Scary Game Wednesdays,
*slam* Awesome Game Thursdays,
*slam* Markiplier Reacts Fridays *chuckling*
Multiplayer Saturdays, *laughter*
*slam* Surprise Sundays!
I don't know, fucking, I don't know whatever I-I-I honestly have no idea that's like a rough idea though
So I have absolutely an idea of what I want to do. So we'll see if it can actually be done
But if not, then it won't be any different and you won't be surprised.
But hey, there's always the possibility
that I will...
do it.
except for the fact that I'm delaying *breaks into laughter*
*laughter*
Shut up! Except for the fact that I am in...
Cincinnati right now and I have to get back to
Uh, Los Angeles and then I have to get back into making videos again, which means that I need a lead-up time to it
so I'm announcing my...
second exile *laughs*
Uh, It's not entirely true- i-it's uh again
this is another lie because it's not like there aren't gonna be videos while I'm away, but everything that I just said-
It won't start until the 14th. 14th? Let me check that. 14th. That's a Monday.
Ok, the 14th of January is when everything else will start back up, what I just said, which is a rough plan
But it's the absolute certainty of the plan that I'm going to do. So, in general sense, and very specific sense,
I will start THOSE up on the 14th
And then I will be TRAVELING back to LA
In the few days and I will lose my mind and not be able to make videos that I explain are...
well thought out and creative. They will be shit.
And also all the other videos that I plan to make in the future will be shit
It's gonna be like Markiplier Makes Mistakes, Markiplier Tries Cocaine,
Uh, Markiplier Reacts to His Own Asshole and
Various other things like that.
That's gonna be like the type of content that you can expect, but it'll be fun...
at least...for me. (laughs)
And that's what really matters right? *laughs*
As much as I always am hard on myself about like (mocking) "Oh, I could work hard" or "Oh, I could do more stuff"
I like... I'm going into this year
with a lot of really...
cool ideas.
A lot of really creative...
c-crazy ideas, but uh, I think it's gonna be a great year.
and even if it's a shit year well
that means there's gonna be a lot of memes about it and hey that's gonna be funny. So can't wait for that
So, let's see if this shit year is gonna be great or if this great year is gonna be shit
You never know which you're gonna get...so
remember that.
Quote me on that, write that on your yearbook.
So thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm gonna get out of here because I got to gett- I go-
I gotta go to the New Year's party or something unless I post this tomorrow and then I gotta
Gotta pack I guess.
But anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you- eh.  don't. don't
I don't wanna know *laughs*
(stutters) Let me know what you think down in the comments below- ah
Whatever
Uh, I'll talk to you guys soon, okay?
I'll be travelling. I'll be losing my mind. Check me out on Twitter. Subscribe.
Slap that like button, ring that bell- ring that bell.
Tell your friends.
I guess there was some important things about this. So if
Uhm
There's people in the community who watch my channel that haven't seen this video yet
Make sure they see it for update sake.
Something like that?
Spread the word! I think that's generally gonna be-
Instead of slapping the like button, smashing the subscribe,
tingling the bell right in the the balls of the bell.
Tell your friends, you know...let them know...
if I have something important to say and I guess this is moderately important to say so.
*clicks tongue*
C'est la vie. See you in the next one. Bye bye!
*quietly* ...what the fuck was that..?